Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 55 und dieses Mal, für den Hörer macht es ja eigentlich keinen Unterschied, aber für mich sehr wohl, dieses Mal kommt die Sendung aus Wien, dem schönen Wien und wir schreiben den 21. November 2007 und diesmal geht es mal um was ganz was anderes und zwar soll unser Thema sein Hacker-Spaces im Allgemeinen und das Metalab in Wien im Besonderen und dazu begrüße ich als Gäste den Enki, hallo, und den Flo. Ihr seid ja beide so ja Teil des Metalab Universums von Anfang an eigentlich?
Ja, ja durchaus.
Kann man so sagen und von Anfang an heißt seit wann ging das alles los?
Ja die Location haben wir vor eineinhalb Jahren bekommen und das Projekt läuft seit drei Jahren.
Okay, und dann sollten wir jetzt auch vielleicht mal erklären, was es ist. Also was ist das Metalab? Was muss man sich darunter vorstellen?
Ja angefangen hat das ganze deshalb, weil wir einen Platz gesucht haben, wo Leute, die technisch interessiert sind, sich außerhalb vom Netz treffen können. Also im echten Leben quasi und gemeinsam reden, Sachen umsetzen und einen Platz haben, um Projekte zu gestalten und zu bauen.
Wir haben einfach gemerkt, es gibt eine ziemlich aktive Szene in Wien, die sich durchaus auch schon in Vereinen, aber auch oft ohne irgendeine fixe Struktur getroffen hat, an Projekten gebastelt hat und die sich über Umwege teilweise gekannt haben, aber doch nicht alle. Und wir haben gesagt, immer irgendwo so nebenbei dranhängend Projekte zu machen, wo das eigentlich gar nicht wirklich den Platz hat, das ist nicht richtig. Wenn wir einen Platz suchen, der einfach nur Infrastruktur ist, wo Leute Projekte machen können, dann können all diese gestrandeten Projekte, die keinen Platz, kein Zuhause gehabt haben, sich dort treffen, austauschen und natürlich auch Synergien zwischen den Projekten sich entwickeln.
Was war denn die Situation vorher in Wien? Also ich meine, was hat die Situation in Wien so unbefriedigend gemacht?
Du hast eine Menge Leute gehabt, die coole Dinge gemacht haben, die online sehr aktiv waren, die man auch gekannt hat, von Mailing-Gästen, von Webseiten, von Projekten, die sie gemacht haben, ab und zu irgendwo auch Veranstaltungen getroffen hat, aber es hat halt keinen Platz gegeben, wo die an ihren Projekten vor Ort gearbeitet haben. Das war oft in Zimmern, das waren Elektronikprojekte, die in Wohnungen entwickelt worden sind und vielleicht einmal auf einer Veranstaltung hergezeigt worden sind und der ganze Prozess des Schaffens, des Bastelns, des Miteinander-Brainstormen ist halt nur immer einer sehr kleinen Gruppe zugänglich gewesen. Jetzt, wo wir eine Location gefunden haben, ist es halt auch einfach so, die Leute arbeiten immer noch in kleinen Gruppen an ihren Projekten, aber oft halt mehrere gleichzeitig. Man kann dort sein, man kann zuschauen, man kriegt einfach mit. Man hat dieses Gefühl von, es ist wirklich was los in Wien.
Und ein ganz wesentlicher Aspekt ist auch, wenn du ein Projekt im Lab umsetzt, dann kriegst du Input, an den du selber nicht gedacht hättest, weil da Leute sind, die davon vielleicht keine Ahnung haben oder einen anderen Zugang haben zur Technik, die dann mit irgendwelchen verrückten Ideen kommen und die dir nie eingefallen werden. Und dadurch blasen sich ganz kleine Ideen oft auch zu riesen Projekten, die dann auch viel cooler sind, als dir das selber jemals gelungen wäre von der Idee her.
Du hast auch auf dem Enki, du hast auf dem Kongress auch mal einen Vortrag dazu gehalten und dann stand das Ganze aber so ein bisschen unter dem Gesamttitel Hacker Spaces. Was hast du da dargestellt und was macht für dich ein Hacker Space aus?
Ein offener Platz, der... also es gibt...
Gibt es denn andere?
Es gibt einige Hacker Spaces. Die Frage ist, wo ziehst du die Grenze? Es gibt einige Gruppen, auch im Security-Bereich schon länger, die sich kleine so Lofts oder was auch immer zehn Personen zusammen an einen Platz genommen haben. Für mich ist aber ein Hacker Space erst dann wirklich ein Hacker Space, wenn er offen ist, wenn er viele verschiedene Interessensgebiete versucht zu vereinern und nicht sagt, das ist unser Thema, sondern sagt, hier ist Raum und coole Leute können coole Projekte damit machen. Ich glaube, das ist eine der starken Eigenheiten, dieses offene Zulassen, dass neue Leute reinkommen und auch den Input, den sie reinbringen, frei zuzulassen.
Ich meine, was heißt dann frei? Also die Tür steht irgendwie den ganzen Tag offen und man kann einfach reinlatschen und machen, was man will.
Es gibt einen, sei es, du weißt, du kannst vorbei schauen, es gibt zumindest einen Tag, wo geöffnet ist, es gibt einen Weg, wie du die Community heißt dich willkommen, dass du reinkommst, zeig dich herum, gib dir eine Möglichkeit, diese Infrastruktur mal zu nutzen. Für dich kannst du nicht alles machen, aber du kannst einfach mal veranfragen, du kannst anfangen, Dinge zu machen, und du musst dir dann halt ausmachen, dass du nicht andere störst. Du kannst natürlich nicht den Raum gleichzeitig nutzen, wenn jemand andere ihn nutzt. Aber prinzipiell steht dir frei dort auch komplett andere Dinge zu machen. Also wir haben Leute gehabt, die haben safen Workshops, wir haben Theateraufförungen gehabt. Wir beschränken uns nicht einfach auf diese Technik. Es ist eher technikaffin oder mit Technologie coole Dinge schaffen, aber es muss nicht immer strikt, es muss nicht frei Software sein, es kann auch Mac sein, es muss nicht Mac sein, es kann auch frei Software sein. Wir haben sogar Windows-Josa.
Ja, den kenne ich auch.
Und Metalab selber ist ein Verein?
Metalab ist als Verein organisiert. In Österreich muss man Vereine anmelden, also es gibt keine Unterscheidung Verein, eingetragener Verein. Jeder Verein muss an der Polizei angezeigt werden und dann muss man abwarten, dass keine Unterlassungserklärung kommt.
Aber man muss sofort angezeigt werden, dann kann man sich dann für später sparen.
Ja, also wir haben jetzt lange Zeit dann mal versucht zu erklären, was wir da eigentlich machen wollen. Ist ja ganz schwer. Du hast in einer Stadt, du hast in anderen Städten gesehen, wie Leute coole Projekte gemacht haben, in den CTC-Clubs, in der Seabase, viele verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen, oft auch einfach gefärbt von den Leuten, die dort sind, von den Interessen, die sie haben. Und dann denkst du dir, du willst sowas hier machen und hast halt einen ganzen Haufen Leute, wo du dir denkst, die passen da sowas von rein, sie kennen uns nur nicht, wie bringst du die rein? Und auch ganz wichtig ihnen zu sagen, wir wollen nicht eure Sache unter unser Label stellen oder so, sondern wir haben einfach mal gesagt, wir wollen die Infrastruktur, die wir gemeinsam nutzen können und dann haben wir auch gemerkt, wir brauchen da Vielfalt, dann haben wir Hardware-Bastler kennengelernt zum Beispiel, haben wir gesagt, super, es wird jede Menge Equipment dort, Hardware-Bastler haben einen Grund vor Ort zu sein, das haben so viele Leute nicht so stark, dadurch ist auch immer gleich wer dort. Dann haben andere Leute gesagt, sie wollen dort Video-Podcasting machen, wieder andere Leute haben gemeint, einfach einen Platz, wo sie coden können, einfach einen Tisch, wo sie gemeinsam rum sitzen können, an sich helfen können bei ihren Problemen, Architektur durchgesprechen und sich immer mehr herauskristallisiert. Was wir brauchen ist einen Platz, der zumindest einen großen Hauptraum hat, wo man Vorträge machen kann, Programmen machen kann und viele kleine, verwinkelte Räume für spezielle Anforderungen. Ob das jetzt das Elektroniklabor ist, das Podcasting-Studio, eine Bibliothek haben wir jetzt eine Zeit lang gehabt, einen Raucherraum, Socializing-Bereich haben wir, Fotolabor, Chemielabor, Küche. Jeden Sonntag haben wir auch ein Gemeinschaftsabendessen. Jeden Sonntag um 20 Uhr.
Mist, da bin ich schon wieder weg. Da bin ich schon wieder weg.
Aber wenn es interessiert, es gibt eine aktuelle Terminliste immer im Wiki auf Metalab.at und da steht dann auch wann was passiert.
Das Wiki ist auch die Hauptwebseite, also eigentlich steht sowieso alles zum Metalab in dem Wiki, oder?
Ja, wir verändern das gerade ein bisschen. Wir haben gemerkt, dass wir früher, als wir angefangen haben, das Ganze zu bauen, jeden Tag die letzten Änderungen 50-mal aufgerufen und sich angeschaut, was tut sich im Wiki. Inzwischen ist es halt so, wir haben da zigtausende Seiten, viele davon sind einfach nicht mehr wachbar. Das heißt, wir schauen jetzt einfach, dass wir ganzen alten Content irgendwo markieren als alt und stattdessen einen Infofolder machen, der geschichtliche Sachen, Veranstaltungsarchiv zusammenfasst. Und auch Kalender möchten wir jetzt auf ein eigenes Kalendersystem verschieben, weil das einfach besser wachbar ist, weil du dann nicht händisch deine Termine warten musst.
So, jetzt hast du aber in dem vorhin gesagt, du warst ein Ort für ein Hacker-Space. Ist das dann sozusagen nur für Hacker und was ist euer Selbstverständnis von dem Begriff Hacker? Erstmal Enki, du hast auch gleich was dazu zu sagen, Flo. Hier kommt jeder zu Wort.
Wir benutzen eigentlich viele verschiedene Begriffe für den Slap. Manchmal sind wir ein Hacker-Space, manchmal ein Jugend-Hangout-Platz, manchmal ein Innovationszentrum, manchmal... Das Metalab sieht sich selbst nach innen hin, meistens als Hacker-Space, aber es ist einfach auch praktisch, sich nicht zu fest an einem Begriff zu klammern. Also manchmal sind wir halt eine Art Jugendzentrum oder so, oder eine WG oder ein Innovationszentrum, oder jede Menge verschiedene Dinge.
Was seid ihr denn gegenüber den Behörden? Was steht denn im Vereinsstatut?
In den Vereinstatuten steht, dass wir der Verein zur Förderung sozialer und technischer Innovationen stehen.
Wow, das klingt doch gut. Und das haben sie auch gefressen.
Das haben sie gefressen.
Das kam zu keiner weiteren Anzeige. Aber ihr habt schon auch eine ganze Menge Gruppen, die jetzt auch hackisch unterwegs sind. Man ist ja schon angeklungen. Es gibt eine ganze Menge Hardware, Bast, Line, Softwareentwicklung. Ist das auch ein Thema im Lab? Was gibt es da?
Ja, ein großes. Also es gibt ein paar Start-ups, die hier schon entstanden sind. Webprojekte. Es gibt auch einige Programme, die schon so webunabhängige Dinge und was mir besonders gut gefällt, weil Enki vorher meinte, dass das Lab hauptsächlich für Hardwareentwickler wichtig ist, weil sie einen Platz haben für Hardware. Das stimmt zwar, aber ich finde auch, dass es für Software große Vorteile bietet, weil du sitzt zum Beispiel im Hauptraum, schreibst dann irgendwas und dir fällt halt grad nicht ein, ob das jetzt String-Copy oder String-Something ist und sagst mal eben so, ah wie heißt denn das Ding, und ein Typ sagt so, ja das ist es, aber nimm doch lieber das, weil das braucht weniger Memo-Overhead. Und das ist so fein, weil du halt irrsinnig schnell effizienter arbeiten kannst, wenn du einfach Feedback sofort hast. Das ist viel besser als vorher.
Ja, aber ganz allgemein, also das ist auch super, wir haben halt Leute zum Beispiel, die setzen sich auch mal hin, zum Beispiel die Yeezy, sie setzt sich öfter mit ihren Mathematikunterlagen hin und wenn du irgendein Problem hast, einen Algorithmus brauchst wegen was, kannst du das auch einfach mit ihr durchspielen. Du hast jede Menge verschiedene Studenten, Berufsgruppen, also nicht alle in der Technik auch berufstätig, das ist dann oft einfach ein Hobby, was nebenher läuft. Aber gerade dadurch bringen sie halt viel Wissen ein aus anderen Sparten.
Wie viele Mitglieder hat das Metalab derzeit?
Ja, mit Karteileichen ca. 140, aber real wahrscheinlich so um 100 rum.
Also real im Sinne von die, die da auch mehr oder weniger regelmäßig aufschlagen und irgendwas tun. Wie groß ist das Metalab?
Wir haben 200 Quadratmeter.
Also man kommt so rein, vielleicht können wir das ja mal so ein bisschen hier die Audio-Welten nutzen, um so ein 3D-Bild im Kopf des Hörers zu erzeugen. Man kommt so irgendwie so rein durch eine niedrige Tür, kleine Treppe, kurzer Gang und dann hat man erst mal den großen Raum. Wie heißt der bei euch? Der Hauptraum. Genau, der Hauptraum. Und dann wird nach hinten jetzt gerade noch viel gebastelt und gebaut. Ihr habt dort eine ganze Menge Energie investiert, um wirklich Dinge zu bauen dort. Musstet ihr da noch viel herrichten, um das Ding ins Haus zu bringen?
Oh ja, jede Menge.
Jede Menge, okay.
Kein nach Arbeit gerade die Reaktion.
Also der ganze Boden, die Heizung, die Küche, die Fliesen, die Wände, die Ausmögen.
Also es ist auch noch eine Wurst zu tun. Ich hab gelernt, das heißt Lounge, der kleine Raucheraum. Der Gesundheitsraum. Genau, der mich sehr beeindruckt hat, weil da auch gleich Dance-Dance-Revolution-Pads direkt in den Boden eingelassen sind. Ist das denn so populär?
Also davor haben wir einen totalen Anflug auf Katamari Damacy gehabt. Katamari Damacy ist ein geniales japanisches Spiel, wo du aus so einem kleinen Ball anfängst und in einer Welt herumrollen. Zuerst mal Streichhölzer, dann irgendwann Zahnpastatuben, dann später Häuser und Elefanten und dann Inseln. Das Spiel ist einfach, du hast zehn Minuten Zeit, so groß wie möglich zu werden mit diesem Ball.
Ah, wie so ein Schneeball sozusagen. Rollt man sich durch die Gegend. Okay, und das haben alle gespielt. Und das war dann der Craze, aber dafür musstet ihr nichts irgendwie in den Boden einlassen.
Aber es hat wieder gelegt.
Das ist so richtig, die kann man fertig kaufen, diese Tanz-Pads. Und die habt ihr euch dann irgendwie in den Boden eingelassen.
Genau, da haben wir einen Laminatboden gemacht aus so Laminatplatten.
Nein, das sind so Holz-Sparplatten. Also, aber wir wollten das Ding generell renovieren, neuen Boden machen, neu ausmalen und da hieß es dann, naja, wenn wir das schon machen, dann könnten wir doch auch gleich diese DDR-Matten da irgendwo verlegen und dazu haben wir halt den Boden auch noch.
Weil die wiegen 14 Kilo, die willst du nicht immer hinschleppen und wieder wegschleppen.
Ja, so sieht es ja auch ganz schick aus, aber es funktioniert auch schon. So, Bima im Rücken und dann hat man so einen kleinen Raum, kann er irgendwie vor sich hin turnen.
Das Dance Dance Revolution öffnet halt auch die Kapitale an, was gut ist für den Gesundheitsraum.
Da wird man die gesunde Luft besser einatmen kann.
Ganz genau, ja.
Ah ja, ich verstehe, okay. So, dann gibt es noch so einen hinteren Raum, der wird, wie schon angedeutet, der wird noch weiter erweitert. Also im Prinzip ist es so eine Erweiterung dieses Hauptraums. Dann gibt es noch so einen kleinen Kellerverlies für Podcaster.
Hab ich gesehen.
Eine schicke Küche. Und dann vor allem recht beeindruckendes Labor. Also so heißt es, ne? Der Raum, wo Hardware gebastelt wird.
Das Wort Everlap, ja.
Das bitte?
Wort Everlap, weil man da was auch immer bauen kann.
Das Wort Everlap. Ja, und da wird auch so einiges gebaut. Also da waren so diverse Roboter am Start und irgendwie alles stand voll mit Oszilloskopen und sonstigen Techniken.
Und eine Drohne haben sie jetzt auch gebaut, inspiriert vom Camp.
Ah ja, das sind dann aber im Prinzip die Projekte von Einzelnen. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass das Metalab sich diese Dinge kauft und dahinstellt, sondern eigentlich ist es mehr so der Ort, wo man dann eben so sich so einen Platz sucht, auch sein Equipment einfach parkt für eine Weile.
Also das ist ganz gemischt. Es gibt natürlich viele Projekte von Leuten, die das mit teilnehmen und halt da bauen. Und es gibt ein paar Projekte, die bleiben da mit im Lab. Zum Beispiel haben wir eine LED-Matrix gebaut mit 3000 LEDs, die wird im Lab bleiben. Dann, also sieh ich, dieses Türschild, dieses blinkende ist auch im Lab entstanden fürs Lab. Und vorige Woche haben wir diesen fetten Lichtschalter gebaut mit drei so kleinen Ostis vorne drauf. Und du kannst da den RGB-Value von der Farbe einstellen. Und oben kleben so 27 RGB-Lights, die die Decke bestrahlen. Und du kannst noch einmal beleuchten in der Farbe, die du selber einstellst. Und auf dem Lichtschalter ist noch so eine kleine Vakuum-Flur-Sensor-Röhre drauf, die dir den aktuellen RGB-Wert anzeigt. Und das ist halt ziemlich cool geworden.
Das ist das Ding, was ich mit dem Podcaster verließ.
Ganz genau, du kannst den Podcaster verließen. Deiner Lieblingsfarbe gestalten.
Das ist ja super. Das hab ich schon gesehen. Dann kann man so drehen und auf einmal ist da irgendwie alles in der passenden Farbe. Ja, das ist schön verspielt. Also ich denke, das zeigt auch eine ganze Menge Hacker-Kultur an der Stelle. War denn das überhaupt ein Problem, so einen Ort zu finden in Wien? Also ich bin ja jetzt nicht so vertraut, wie einfach das jetzt hier ist. Das Finden war schon schwieriger. Ich hör ja häufig aus anderen Städten so, ja, sowas hätten wir ja auch gerne, aber geht gar nicht.
Das Schwierige war nicht das Finden vom Platz. Da haben wir Glück gehabt, da haben wir zuerst eine andere Location vorher noch gehabt, die auch fast gepasst hätte. Klar, wir haben jetzt ein Riesenglück gehabt mit diesem tollen Platz. Viel besser wäre es nie und nimmer gegangen. Das Schwierige war einfach mal zunächst den Leuten zu erklären, was es ist und genug Leute zu finden, die sagen, wir zahlen das gemeinsam. Weil du fängst nicht einfach mal an mit irgendeinem abstrosen Plan und gehst wohin und holst dir Förderungen oder sonst was, sondern wir haben gesagt, wir müssen das selber finanzieren können. Wir brauchen genug Leute, dass es wirklich einen Sinn macht. Und dann brauchst du mal, haben wir mal lange, über Jahre eigentlich mal diese Idee rumgespielt, irgendwann angefangen, eine Unterschriftenliste zu machen. Und wenn du dann mal Leute hast, die sagen, sie zahlen 20 Euro im Monat, dann hast du einen gewissen Geldbetrag, mit dem du rechnen kannst. Dann musst du eigentlich nur noch rumlaufen täglich und schauen, in den Bezirken, die dich interessieren, gibt es da freie Locations.
Das heißt, das Prinzip ist, dass das Metalab sich finanziell selbst trägt?
Ganz genau, ja.
Ohne nennenswerte Zuwendungen. Sollte es sowas geben, dann fördert das eher die Infrastruktur und so weiter.
Infrastruktur, Projekte, Renovierungen, aber alles einmalig.
Und da habt ihr dann diese 100 Leute sozusagen auch wirklich gebraucht?
Also unsere Rechnung war eigentlich, wir wollten zuerst ein Lokal, das 800 Euro billiger war. Das haben wir aber verloren, weil das hat eine Theaterkonzession und der Besitzer wollte das lieber an eine Theatergruppe geben. Und dann sind wir erstmal da gestanden und dann ist irgendwie auch schon ein bisschen das Vertrauen, schaffen wir das jetzt noch, eine Location zu finden und so. Schon wieder angefangen ein bisschen abzuäben. Und dann hat jemand einen Parkplatz gesucht, der Peter, in der Gegend. Und hat zufällig dieses Lokal gefunden, hat sich mal erkundigt, hat gesagt, gut, das ist aber 800 Euro zu teuer. Dann haben wir rumgerechnet, rumdiskutiert und hin und her zwischendurch noch überlegt, ob wir ein Drittel so großes Lokal in einem Außenbezirk nehmen sollen, klein anfangen und wachsen. Und irgendwann haben wir dann einfach gesagt, nein, okay, wenn wir es schaffen, dass jetzt mal 40 Leute auf einmal 240 Euro, also einen Jahresbeitrag, zahlen, dann können wir anfangen, haben sechs Monate Zeit, unsere Mitgliederzahlen zu verdoppeln, und dann geht sich das aus. Und dann haben wir gesagt, wir gehen das Risiko ein und es hat geklappt.
Wie war denn so die Risikobereitschaft bei allen? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man da so einige Überzeugungsarbeit hat leisten müssen, um dann so einzelne auch mitzuziehen, oder war so der Druck auf alle mit, oh Gott, wir haben sowas nicht, wir brauchen sowas, so große Druck?
Nein, die Angst war riesig und auch der Zweifel, die Skeptik, ob das überhaupt möglich ist, was das ist, wie das Sinn macht. Es hat auch angefangen damit, dass so einige Hardcore-Techniker haben Angst gehabt vor Partys, Veranstaltungen, Nicht-Technikern. Die Nicht-Techniker haben gemeint, das ist zu vernerdet. Alle haben irgendwie Angst gehabt, wir können das nicht machen, weil es wird nicht klappen, das zusammenräumen usw. Es hat sich auch gezeigt, dass es nicht funktioniert, aber der Platz läuft halt trotzdem. Also es war viel Angst einfach so, wenn das, also wenn A, dann geht das nicht. Und wir haben einfach gesagt, gut, wenn die Probleme auftreten, werden wir auch noch Lösungen finden, wir müssen mal anfangen.
Wie werden denn Entscheidungen gefällt? Also ich meine, mit so einem Verein, gut, es wird sicherlich einen Vorstand geben. Die Frage ist, ist das dann nur das Gremium der Verantwortlichen und Schuldigen, oder sind das auch die, die dann die Entscheidungen fällen?
Es kommt natürlich auf die Frage da an, wenn es jetzt darum geht, jemand hat die Idee, jetzt 10.000 € auszugeben für einen Plasmashred-Screen, dann wird man das vielleicht mal eben mit einem Vorstand abklären und mal drüber nachdenken, ob das jemand macht, Geld für sowas auszugeben. Und dann wird die Entscheidung natürlich nicht von Einzelpersonen getroffen, wenn es mal um große Geldbetriebe geht. Wenn es jetzt darum geht, in welcher Farbe man die Decke anstreicht oder welche Lampen man aufhängt, dann setzt man sich in der Gruppe zusammen, macht ein Konzept und dann findet man einen Konsens und dann macht man das. Und meistens ist es so, dass Entscheidungen dann erst getroffen werden von Leuten, die es sehr gerne machen. Vor allem in Sachen, die wenig Budget fressen. Kaufst du dir die Farbe, die dir gefällt und streichst die Tür in dieser Farbe an. Und erstaunlicherweise klappt das ziemlich gut. Ich habe gedacht, dass am Anfang, wenn da zu viele verschiedene enkende Menschen aufeinandertreffen, dass das total zerfällt und ein Teil so aussieht und ein Teil so. Aber ja, solange sie sich in einem gewissen Rahmen bewegt, kann der Einzelne da durchaus machen, was ihm gerade gefällt. Und das passt alles sehr gut zusammen. Und ich mag ja am Lebbruch sehr gerne diese ganzen kleinen Details, die man erst sieht, wenn man schon länger da ist. Und die Leute ein bisschen kennenlernen, fallen immer auf diese ganzen Sachen auf, die irgendwo in einem Eck hängen, und man sich denkt, ah ja, das ist von dem.
Die kleinen Scribbles und Zeichnungen zum Beispiel, die da so versteckt sind. Davon gibt es ja eine Menge. Das sind auch einfach auch sehr schöne Installationen. Ich habe jetzt noch nicht so viel Zeit verbracht, seitdem ich hier in Wien bin, aber es war sofort auffällig, dass halt der Raum, der wird gelebt, also Leute halten sich dort auf und betrachten das offensichtlich als ihr Wohnzimmer und gestalten das dann halt auch dementsprechend. Da, wo man sich zu Hause fühlt, da steckt man natürlich auch immer am meisten Energie rein. Tuft das so zu, mein Eindruck? Wie ist denn so die, das wird hier erst mal angerufen. Wir legen das beiseite. Nichts ist wichtiger als ein neuer Chaosradio Express-Podcast. Diese hundert Leute, diese Mitglieder, man hat ja schon ein bisschen gesagt, das sind so alle möglichen Arten und Gruppen, also so Start-up-wütige Techniker, Nicht-Techniker. Kannst du vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr zu dieser Struktur sagen, was da so, wie paradiesisch sich das jetzt wirklich aufhaltet? Und vor allem, wie die Altersstruktur ist. Das würde mich ja nochmal interessieren.
Also meine Schätzung ist, wir haben einen Median-Alter von ungefähr 26. Wir haben jede Menge...
Ein Median-Alter?
Median.
Ah, ein mittleres, dein Telefon. GSM-ifiziert hier unsere Aufnahme-Kanäle.
Ja, wir haben jede Menge verschiedene Leute. Also es reicht von Physikern, Chemiker, Mathematiker, Linguistiker, Schüler, Arbeitslose, Studenten, Gründer, Konsultants, Weinbauern.
Der 26. Durchschnitt ist jetzt ermittelt oder geraten? Und wo geht's los und wo hört's auf?
Bei 14 und es hört auf irgendwo bei 65 oder so.
Das klingt ja so nach der typischen Chaos-Computer-Club-Altersstruktur, wo es auch irgendwie früh losgeht und die Leute dann bis ins Rentenalter nicht loslassen können.
Wir sind der Struktur von TTC auch sehr ähnlich, was auch Hintergründe betrifft und Motivationen. Unter anderem war es ja auch so, dass es keinen Chaos-Computer-Club Wien gab über lange Zeit, sondern eine chaosnahe Gruppe, hieß die. Und deren Ziel war es ja auch, einen Platz zu finden, um das auszuüben, was ihnen aber ein paar Jahre lang nicht gelungen ist, weil die Gruppe halt nicht groß genug war. Und die sind jetzt bei uns halt auch runtergekommen. Wir haben jetzt auch einen TTC Wien und der macht seine Treffen auch im Metalab. Aber ich würde sagen, es gibt schon einen sehr großen Unterschied zu dem großen TTC in Deutschland, weil wir halt noch nicht so alt sind. Uns gibt es jetzt gerade mal eineinhalb, zwei Jahre. Und der TTC hat halt eine lange Vergangenheit, dadurch entstehen auch viele Strukturen, die man nachher... Ich meine, der TTC ist ein sehr lebhafter Verein, da passiert sehr viel, aber es gibt halt Strukturen, die sich schwer ändern lassen, oder wo immer viel diskutiert werden muss.
Es sind halt viele Leute bei uns noch nie in so einer Struktur gewesen. Ein paar Leute haben gesehen, das funktioniert, das könnte man vielleicht anders machen, eigener Touch reingebracht. Und dann ist es mal ein Großteil von Leuten, die teilweise noch nie in Vereinen waren. Wir haben ursprünglich auch gedacht, viele Leute von Vereinen, haben gedacht, 10GW, Funkfeuer, Luger, Quintessence und so weiter, wenn die Vereine da gemeinsam sich einen Platz nehmen. Was ich dann mal gezeigt habe, ist, die Vereine haben auch schon ihre Strukturen und ein Großteil der Leute jetzt ist einfach, waren nirgends, haben einfach einen Platz gesucht, haben nicht einmal Anschluss gehabt, irgendwo an die Szene teilweise. Und das ist ganz spannend, weil dadurch haben wir irgendwo, sind wir jetzt ein sozusagen, in vielerlei Inzicht sind wir YouTube-Generation. Also was mir auffällt, sind bei uns die Leute, die Web-2.0-Applikationen und dergleichen, ich hab das böse Wort gesagt, interaktive, moderne Web-Applikationen, Daten hergeben, die eigentlich niemand sehen sollte, deutlich weniger skeptisch. Also Datenschutz ist zwar ein großes Thema, aber ein Thema, wo man meist die Pragmatik einfach siegt. Ich will das benutzen, ich will das machen, es wird gemacht, wenn ich es nicht mach, macht es wer anderer.
Weniger Paranoia?
Weniger Paranoia.
Teilweise. Also es kommt natürlich auf die Leute darauf an, aber ich denk mir halt, es gibt Leute, die haben eine Myspace-Seite, und das spricht halt schon für sich, sag ich mal. Also ich finde es nicht unbedingt gut, ich habe keine, aber ich denke, so was im TTC halt wahrscheinlich echt kaum...
Du hast auch keinen Musiker, oder?
Nein, aber ich glaube, das ist auch nur ein Nutzl von den Leuten auf Myspace.
Ist das so? Ja, vielleicht zahlenmäßig, aber ich glaube, an Nutzung kommt es am meisten. Da hatten wir ja vor zwei Ausgaben schon mal das Thema ausführlich bestrungen.
Also das Lab ist halt relativ zu großen Teilen auf Gsing und Co. und Social-Networking-Seiten und was auch immer vertreten. Wird das dann auch diskutiert?
Also, ich meine, ist das dann auch... Gibt es auch eine inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung? Oder ist das Metalab jetzt einfach nur so der Hobbykeller von allen und man trifft sich irgendwie...
Es gibt eine inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung, aber es gibt halt auch, im Unterschied zum CCC, nicht eine offizielle Meinung. Es gibt prinzipiell die Meinungen vom Vereinet. Solches nach Ausdien beschränken sich auf allgemeinen Bedingungen, solche Plätze schaffen zu können und Projekte in den anderen durchzuführen. Wir haben sicher auch Revalität. Es gibt irgendwo nicht die Schiene, die sagt, du darfst dich nicht anmelden. Es ist weniger vielleicht auch sozialer Druck. Es ist böse, dass du jetzt singen oder was benutzt und deine Daten da als Freiwild allen zur Verfügung stellst. Es gibt eher die Diskussion, so informationelle Selbstbestimmung. Es geht auch in die Richtung, im Lab würden wir nie Kameras installieren, aber ein Bewegungsmelder ist okay, weil der nicht personalisiert ist.
Aber ich meinte jetzt gar nicht so sehr im Hinblick auf das Metalab verkörpert eine einheitliche Meinung in die Öffentlichkeit, sondern eher inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung, ob das Teil des Vereinslebens ist. Also ich meine, beim Club gibt es so einer dieser alten Zöpfe, das sind so Plenumssitzungen, ja, man sitzt dann irgendwie mal so einmal die Woche zusammen und dann wird halt mal mehr, mal weniger, aber auch wirklich intensiv jetzt über Netzpolitisches zum Beispiel diskutiert. Gibt es so solche Runden?
Ja, es gibt intern sehr viele Diskussionen und wir sind jeder für sich sehr aktiv, auch teilweise politisch aktiv. Was nur sehr wichtig ist und auch ganz klar gesagt wurde, ist, dass der Verein Metalab keine politischen Ziele verfolgt oder repräsentiert, sondern dass wir einen Platz haben, wo wir halt unseren Zielen nachgehen können und die Umsetzung...
Wo aber Gruppen durchaus sich einfinden können, die dann politische Ziele verfolgen. Nicht die Piratenpartei?
Ja, das ist eher ein Sonderfall. Das ist ein Thema, da wird manchmal in die eine Richtung zu scharf geschossen, manchmal in die andere. Generell gilt bei uns auch einfach die Meinung, man muss sich auf beiden Seiten ehren von einem Thema, weil wenn man sich nur auf einer Seite ehren, liegt man wahrscheinlich falsch. Also Piratenbeteiligung ist halt nicht wirklich eine irgendwo vertretende Partei, sondern das ist hauptsächlich auch ein Platz, um interessierte Leute zusammen zu bringen. Und das ist genau das, was wir auch machen wollen, Leute, die sich für aktuelle Themen interessieren, für Projekte interessieren, Dinge machen wollen, zusammenzubringen. Also wenn die jetzt da ihre Parteiblattform aufbauen würden, also als Wahlbüro oder was auch immer in der Art, dann würde das sicher Unbehagen auslösen. Das hat auch schon einmal...
Aber es ist so ein Ort, wo auch solche Dinge entstehen können?
Es wären auch Dinge von dort aus organisiert, Veranstaltungen, nur gerade wenn es jetzt auch um Copyright-Themen und so geht, die einfach wirklich viele Leute in der Gruppe beschäftigen, kommst du nicht ganz drum herum, einfach einen Standpunkt zu haben, nicht nur als Privatperson, sondern wenn einfach alle fast schon der gleichen Meinung sind, kriegt der Verein natürlich auch eine Färbung in der Richtung.
Stellt denn das Metalab seinen Mitgliedern eigentlich auch irgendwelche Dienstleistungen bereit? Also kriegt man gleich einen Mail-Account, wenn man da irgendwie reinmarschiert, oder gibt es sonst irgendwelche Dinge?
Ja, das Metalab hat viele Sachen, die du zu Hause nicht hast zur Verfügung. Also wir haben zum Beispiel die Bibliothek ist jetzt gerade im Umbau, aber wir haben da Bücher stehen, die du nicht kaufen willst, weil sie einfach schweineteuer sind. Oder, ich meine, Compilerbücher sind was, was du wirklich nicht jedenfalls brauchst. Und stehen halt rum. Kann man sich nehmen, wenn man nachschauen will. Und in der Hardware-Ecke gibt es eine CNC-Frieze, die man sich vielleicht auch nicht zu Hause hinstellen will, weil auch gar kein Platz dafür ist und das Zeug teuer ist. Und eine Werkstatt und Oszilloskope und Messgeräte. Und ein Fotolabor, das hat man vielleicht auch nicht in seinem Badezimmer. Abgesehen vom Platz selber. Also Melon-Account kriegst du in Metalabs jetzt mal keinen. Aber es gibt Internet. Ja, der Internet natürlich gibt es ihn heute.
Natürlich gibt es Internet. Ja, das ist die neue Generation. Da muss man gar nicht drüber nachdenken bzw. gar nicht erst drüber reden.
Ja, wir haben Funkfeuerknoten am Dach. Das ist so ein freies Netz in Wien.
Das ist Mesh-Networking. Genau, das hatten wir auch schon hier zweimal ausführlich diskutiert bei Chaosradio Express. Und Funkfeuer ist so das Projekt in Wien. Und darüber seid ihr angebunden.
Und wir haben noch eine zweite Anbindung, die wir eigentlich hauptsächlich nutzen, die ESDSL.
Und, wie schnell kommt das dann da rein?
Es sollten 12 MBits sein in die eine Richtung, aber das klappt nicht ganz. Es sind eher so acht.
Ja, letztes Mal als ich es ausprobiert habe, war es eigentlich ganz performant. Von daher reicht es auf jeden Fall aus. Okay, also es gibt Internet, aber es gibt sonst keine elektronischen Dienstleistungen, sondern die Dienstleistung ist ja nicht mehr in Ordnung.
Na ja, wir haben halt den Java-Server, wir haben die Mailing-Listen, wir haben immer wieder Events, wir kriegen Einladungen zu anderen Events oder was gratis rein. Also da hat zum Beispiel dieses Jahr der Europäische Go-Kongress in Villach, da hat es zu den Vorträgen gratis Eintritt für Metalab-Mitglieder gegeben und so. Aber das ist alles so auf der sozialen Ebene. Infrastruktur, ja, es bauen Leute Dinge, wo du Zugang kriegst. In Wirklichkeit zu diesen Dingen machen wir nicht so wirklich Zugangskontrolle. Was du primär vom Mitgliedsbeitrag kriegst, ist halt einfach Mitspracherecht. Du kannst mitgestalten, du kriegst mit, was sich auf deinen Diskussionslisten tut. Das heißt, wir schicken niemanden weg, der einfach mal zu Besuch da ist, wegen einer Veranstaltung da ist. Du kriegst auch nicht sofort irgendwo penetrant ein Mitgliedsformular in die Hand gedrückt. Das funktioniert eigentlich in Maßen ganz gut, weil jene Leute, die mitsprechen wollen, mit der Zeit, wenn du wirklich involviert bist, willst du halt mitsprechen, willst du mitgestalten.
Wie ist denn das mit Veranstaltungen? Ich fände ja auch von Zeit zu Zeit Veranstaltungen im Metalab statt. Ich weiß nicht, ich fange euch da jetzt gerade mal so ein paar ein, die man nennen könnte, um da so das Panoptikum...
Nein, das bisher, was am besten läuft, ist der Meta-Day. Das ist einfach ein Tag, wo wir sagen, wir haben viele Mitglieder. Ich schätze jetzt mal so, ein Drittel ist zu jedem Zeitpunkt wirklich aktiv, ein Drittel ist ein bisschen weniger aktiv und ein Drittel ist gerade nicht da. Also wir machen einen Tag, wo die Leute, die beruflich oder aus sonstigen Gründen nicht so oft zur Zeit kommen, wissen, da können sie kommen. Da sind viele Leute da, da ist ein cooles Programm.
Ah, doch Plenum.
Nein, Meta-Day ist mehr so, wir laden unseren Speaker ein. Also da war, der Starbug war zum Beispiel da über Biometriesysteme und verschiedenste Themenbereiche. Ich glaube, in Zukunft kommt einmal ein Vortragender über aktueller Status von künstlicher Intelligenz. Wir haben E-Voting als ein Thema gehabt, Biometriesysteme, Bluetooth-Security, letztens Wien aus Ungarn da gehabt, von einem ähnlichen, deutlich kleiner Projekt, das heißt Next Lab in Budapest. Der hat halt vorgestellt, was es dort so für Projekte machen. Und danach machen wir Lightning Talks. Das ist eher so, teilweise kriegen wir da 100, 120 Leute sogar in so einen Saal rein, also das staut sich dann manchmal schon im Gang nach hinten vom Hauptraum weg. Und gerade die Lightning Talks sind interessant. Da stellen dann Leute aktuelle Projekte vor, was sie gebastelt haben, was sie gerade gemacht haben, neue Software, die sie fürs Lab geschrieben haben.
Also Lightning Talks sollte man vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären. Das ist das Konzept, dass jeder 5 Minuten bekommt.
4 Minuten machen wir, das ist ein bisschen mit einer Gnadenminute sozusagen. Wo du dich einfach vorne hinstellst, mit oder ohne Laptop, wenn mit Laptop, dann aber schon ganz fertig, fix anschnecken. Und einfach mal erklären, irgendein Thema. Da haben wir Königsberger Brückenprobleme schon mal erklärt bekommen, Quanten-Kryptographie in 4 Minuten, die neue Zugangssysteme, alles Mögliche, sondern in 4 Minuten geht ziemlich viel.
Das ist ja cool. Und wie lange geht das dann?
Meistens haben wir so 5, manchmal sogar mehr, so 5 bis 10 Vortragende, die Lightning Talks vorstellen.
Und das wird dann auch erst an dem Abend sozusagen, kann man sich da einschreiben. Also man kommt da hin und sagt, da fällt mir auch noch was zu ein, das mache ich jetzt einfach.
Es geht einfach so lange weiter, man kann sich voreintragen, aber in Wirklichkeit geht es einfach so lange weiter, bis keine Lightning Talks mehr da sind. Danach ein bisschen socialisen, Wein trinken oder irgendwelche Toasts machen.
Das ist einmal im Monat?
Das ist einmal im Monat.
Gibt es da einen festen Tag?
Ich glaube der erste Freitag im Monat.
Und dann so auf den Abend?
Ja, steht dann auch immer im Wiki als Meta-Day.
Okay, also das ist sozusagen auch wirklich vom Metalab fürs Metalab, auch um gerade die Leute einzubinden, die jetzt, was weiß ich, vielleicht Mitglieder sind, aber das eigentlich auch eher so machen, weil sie irgendwie den Laden als solchen Zapfer wollen.
Aber wir holen uns halt Vortragende. Es kann durchaus mal passieren, dass es ein Vortragender von intern ist, aber da ist einfach schon der Kontakt da. Da ist es einfach die Wahrscheinlichkeit da, dass sie uns mit dem Thema schon auskennen. Was jetzt spannend wäre, ist, denke ich, einen Gissexperten, also Geoinformationssysteme, uns zu holen. Vielleicht sogar wen, der von der Stadt kennt, diese Pläne, in welchen Formaten die vorlegen, wo man die kriegt, der uns erklärt, wie kommt man die Gisdaten von der Stadt ran? Gibt es da Testzugänge? Was kann man damit machen? Wie funktioniert das? Wie funktionieren die Koordinatensysteme? Es kann auch einfach ein Anstoß sein, dass neue Dinge loskommen. Das andere wäre zum Beispiel das RFID-Projekt, von dem, was ich am Kongress gesehen habe. Sputnik, das wäre zum Beispiel spannend. Das wäre auch wieder so ein Anstoß. Open Moko wäre auch ein Projekt, wo man sich denken könnte, mal wen zu holen.
Also schon vom Querschnitt, was ich so höre, schon, aber Technik und Gesellschaft, viel von dem, was man auch auf den Kongress so bekommt. Da merkt man aber auch schon, dass es ein Hacker-Space ist, als ein Hacker.
Ja, ganz genau. Und besonders, ich meine, das im Moment kümmert sich der Peter besonders darum, einfach interessante Vortragende zu finden. Jetzt kommt Hochspannungselektrik, das ist zum Beispiel auch so ein Thema irgendwo, Tesla-Spulen, einfach Dinge, die Anstoß geben. Und halt viele andere. Zu guten Zeiten haben wir drei bis vier Vorträge, Workshops im Lab in jeder Woche. Ist dann im Sommer ein bisschen weniger, in Zeiten, wenn viele Leute gerade beschäftigt sind mit anderen Projekten?
In jeder Woche habt ihr drei Vorträge?
Das kommt auf die Woche an. Manchmal ist es so, dass zwei Wochen nix ist, und dann ist sogar jeden Tag was hintereinander.
Hab ich heute schon wieder irgendwas verpasst?
Nein, diese Woche ist wegen der Konferenzen jetzt, DeepSec, RoboExotica, das sind alles so bis oben hin faul.
Und an Veranstaltungen, die jetzt nicht so sehr aus Metalab-Urschleim sich zehren, was kommt dann so zu Gast?
Wir haben den Web-Montag schon ein paar Mal bei uns gehabt. Das ist so der lokale Web-Entwickler-Stammtisch. Also wirklicher Entwickler, auch da, was selten ist auf diesen ganzen New-Economy-Stammtischen. Alles, was irgendwo ein bisschen entwicklerlastig ist, die Free Software Foundation Europe, Wien trifft sich hier. Also manche Künstlergruppen, Gaming-Schuhe-Fixer, es ist auch von wirklichen Spieler-Entwicklern. Demo-Szene-Treffen haben wir schon gehabt. Es steht in Wirklichkeit offen. Also im Grunde die Policy ist, man muss halt von den 40 Leuten, die einen Schlüssel haben, irgendwie entschnappen, dass er aufsperrt und ein bisschen den Liaison zum Lab macht. Da kann in Wirklichkeit jede Gruppe eine Veranstaltung machen. Man kann im Grunde alles im Lab machen, bis irgendwo dann Einsprüche kommen, dass es übermäßige Benutzung, das stört, dass die Räume nicht zusammen. Da muss man es halt ausdiskutieren.
Also, ihr nehmt jetzt auch nicht für alles Geld, sondern das entheckt immer ein bisschen davon ab, wie sehr das so in den eigenen Kontext ist.
Nein, wir haben keine Veranstaltungen, wo die Leute dafür zahlen. Es sind dann auch so Vereinbarungen. Wir haben zum Beispiel einen Regie-Workshop gehabt und einen Fotografier-Workshop, wo einzelne Teilnehmer, glaube ich, mitessen, 15 Euro pro Tag gezahlt haben. Für Metalab-Members war das dann gratis. Dafür haben sie das Lab nutzen können als Ort. Also, so in die Richtung.
Wir versuchen nur, wo Kosten entstehen. Aber im Großen und Ganzen sind Mitglieder zahlen auch ihr Mitgliedsbeitrag jedes Monat erst bei 20 Euro momentan. Dadurch hast du auch das Recht, alles zu benutzen und mitzumachen bei allen Veranstaltungen. Wenn du kein Member bist, kannst du dir mal vorbeikommen und dir das alles anschauen. Es wird sicher niemandem heimgeschickt, nur weil er jetzt nichts zahlt dafür.
Wenn uns jetzt einer zuhört und sich denkt, oh, Metalab ist ja toll, wie kommt er dann zu euch? Wo ist das Metalab?
Das Metalab ist in der Rathausstraße 6 in Wien, das ist im ersten Bezirk, neben einem Rathaus.
Also regierungsnah.
Ja, ganz sicher.
Also im ersten Bezirk, also mitten in der Stadt.
Wir haben einen eigenen U-Bahn-Aufgang bei der U2, wo man raufkommt und das Leibsungsfahrt sieht, also keine zwei Minuten von dort.
Und es ist eigentlich auch immer offen?
Es ist fast 24-7 Uhr offen, aber ich würde trotzdem, wenn man keinen Schlüssel hat, schaut man entweder auf die Webseite, wir haben so einen Sensor, der sagt, der ist gerade geöffnet, es gibt ein Telefon, man kann anrufen, das ist die 027 00 23 23 und...
Ach, dann geht vielleicht jemand ran. Achso, ich dachte, das wäre so eine Computerstimme, die sagt, das Metalab ist geschlossen.
Meistens hebt dann irgendwer ab und meint so Friedhof Stammerstorf Süd oder... Man muss da schon wissen, wo man angerufen hat, das muss ich auskennen.
Und wenn jetzt Leute so ein bisschen Blut gelegt haben und sich denken, das könnte ja dann auch was für mich sein, was würdet ihr denen raten?
Ja, kommt vorbei. Also am Abend ist immer jemand da, auf der Webseite ist halt der aktuelle Status, den man ablesen kann.
Und beim ersten Mal ist es vielleicht nicht so blöd, wenn man mal an einen Tag kommt mit einem eingetragenen Termin, weil es sind zwar die meisten Leute sehr freundlich und fuhren gerne herum und erklären Dinge, aber es ist halt... Dann hat man halt vielleicht am nächsten Tag eine Deadline, sei es für die Uni oder für einen Kunden, und ist dann doch nicht ganz so freundlich. Also es ist schade, wir haben manchmal Leute, die kommen rein, es kümmert sich niemand um sie, es kann auch grad niemand. Die gehen dann wieder, kommen vielleicht nie wieder. Also am besten beim ersten Mal, bevor man Leute kennt, bevor man schon sich ein bisschen zurechtfindet, zu Veranstaltungen kommen.
Wie zum Beispiel den Metaday? Metalab hat ja auch so sein eigenes Fernsehprogramm.
Ja.
Ein Videopodcast, Alert the Internets.
Schon mal gehört? Ich weiß nur grad ein bisschen, was gerade verwirrt wird.
Ja, ich finde, das ist ja das eigentliche Fernsehen. Das macht der Kevaghi, macht er auch sehr unterhaltsam. Das sind ja immer lustige Ausschnitte aus dem täglichen Metalab-Leben zu sehen.
Das ist so die Metalab Soap-Opera.
Das ist die Soap-Opera.
Ich frage mich immer, ob man als Außen-Spieler versteht, was da so passiert. Weil oft sind das viele Anspielereien auf irgendwelche Dinge.
Es sind schrecklich viele In-Jokes. Es ist in sich verstrickt. Es ist wahrscheinlich ganz nett von außen so betrachtet. Aber es ist eine sehr satirische Betrachtung von dem Leben, was einfach passiert. Und von den Streitigkeiten in aktuellen Themen. Von blöden Witzen. Also ich meine, die LOL-Cat-Zeit zum Beispiel war horrend. Das Lab ist einer der infektiösesten Plätze für so Meme. Wo die ganzen Internet-Scherze überschwemmern uns. Bis zum Exzess. Bis wir uns einfach schon gegenseitig schlagen. Nichts ist nicht mehr außerhalb. Und Schmerzen leiden. Wir haben geglaubt, LOL-Cats zum Beispiel haben wir überstanden, aber sie machen immer wieder auch ein Comeback.
Also schwierig. Aber ist es nicht so ein bisschen gelebtes Internet? Die physikalische Kopie dessen, was man eigentlich sozial im Internet abfeiert?
Das ist die Erweiterung der Internetsozialnetzwerksache.
Aber damit zerstört ihr noch die Illusion, dass Leute, die im Internet sind, sozial verarmen, keinen Spaß haben und nur darüber nachdenken, wann sie irgendwie ihre Mitschüler erschießen können.
Ach, ist das so? Ich dachte immer, die Leute, die auf diesem Social-Network sind, sind deshalb da, weil sie gerne 10.000 Freunde haben, die nicht mit ihnen schlafen wollen. Ist das nicht die Idee?
Ja, aber ganz ernsthaft. Ich meine, es sind ja eigentlich auch alles netzaffine Menschen, die im Metalab abhängen. Absolut, ja.
Nicht ausschließlich. Wir haben Leute, die sind dazugekommen, einfach wegen Freunden dort und so. Die haben vorher nicht einmal noch ein Wiki bedient oder wirklich benutzt oder so. Und die benutzen das jetzt, aber die bringen halt anderes Dinge mit. Die basteln dort halt coole Dinge, machen Deko, helfen bei Veranstaltungen, organisieren Dinge. Das ist irgendwie das Coole. Das Lab hat so viele Imperfektionen, so viele Dinge, die unfertig sind, dass irgendwie jeder irgendwo eine Nische findet, wo er was verbessern kann. Und dann andere Leute, die kritisieren oder im negativen Sinne und im positiven Sinne sagen, einfach, pff, ist das cool, das hat gefehlt. Das ist so geil, da kann man auch das dazu machen. Du kriegst Feedback, du machst irgendwas.
Jetzt läuft das Lab seit anderthalb Jahren?
Ja, anderthalb Jahren. Wir haben am 10. April, drei Tage, bevor dann die Easter Hack damals notübersiedelt ist, ins Metalab den Schlüssel bekommen, glücklicherweise.
Und das ist ja jetzt schon, das ist vielleicht noch ein recht frischer Ort, aber trotzdem dürftet ihr auch schon so einige Lehren aus dem bisherigen Geschehen gezogen haben. Wenn jetzt andere Leute darüber nachdenken, in ihrer Stadt einen solchen Hacker-Space aufzumachen, der sich in mehreren Gruppen öffnet, was habt ihr denn da so für Tipps und Ratschläge bei der Hand?
Ja jede Menge, jede Menge, jede Menge.
Einfach mal anfangen, eine Doku zu machen und daran zu feilen und regelmäßig Updates zu geben und nicht irgendwie davon ablenken lassen, dass...
Updates zu geben jetzt für wen? Also für die Gruppe...
Unbedingt jeder, der sich mal dafür interessiert, irgendwo...
Also als Erstes geht man los und versucht, so viele Leute einzusammeln...
Erstmal macht man ein Dokodokument, das du in die Hand drücken kannst, fängst einfach mal an, deine eigene Vision zu verfeinern und dann, wenn du Leute irgendwie auch nur in den leisesten Klima im Auge erkennst, dass sie das machen wollen, dann sammelst du die Kontaktdaten. Du holst sie auf den Java-Server, irgendwo, wo du sie weiter mit Updates versorgen kannst. Und jede Woche, wenn du beim Stammtisch allein sitzt und es kommt niemand hin, dann schickst du trotzdem ein Update nachher raus, was ich getan hab. Du hältst die Leute am Laufen, du zeigst, die Leute brauchen eine Weile, dass einfach konstanter weitergearbeitet wird. Ich stecke keine Energie in ein Projekt, das in einem Monat tot ist. Und das wächst dann. Dann kommen mehr Leute dazu. Und dann einfach nicht abschrecken lassen, von was schiefgehen könnte, was nicht funktionieren wird. Nicht Probleme lösen, die in drei Monaten auftreten, sondern einfach nur mit dem Jetzt beschäftigen. Wenn in drei Monaten das Geld... Also man kann vordenken, klar, das ist ein komplett unrealistischer Finanzplan, wird man nicht machen. Aber es könnte schiefgehen. Und ich habe aber keine Lösung, wie ich es besser mache, nicht die Gedanken damit verbringen, einfach mal machen. Leute zuziehen, wachsen, Enthusiasmus verbreiten. Und es wächst, es wird cool, es spricht sich herum. Und irgendwann klappt es dann einfach. Auch zusammenräumen, das sind alles Dinge, die kann man lösen, wenn die Location dreckig ist. Das Wichtige ist, dass du irgendwas hast, wo du dich festhalten kannst. Bei uns waren das die Mailing-Listen, Java und vor allem dieser Info-Folder. Der hat es bei uns zwar gar nicht in den Druck geschafft, aber allein dadurch, dass wir einen schön designten Info-Folder als Beruf gehabt haben, haben die Leute gesehen, wir meinen es ernst. Wir wollen das machen.
Ich kann mich dem nur anschließen, und ich finde, die wichtigste Quintessenz von dem Ganzen ist, dass du Probleme dann löst, wenn sie auftreten. Da haben wir uns im Vorhinein so viel Kopf gemacht über Sachen, wie könnten wir das lösen, wenn dann die Raucher mal auf die Nichtraucher treffen würden, angenommen, das könnte jemanden stören. Es war dann, wie es soweit war, eine lange Diskussion, und dann hat sich das auch wieder eingependelt, und jetzt funktioniert das. Jetzt ist es so, dass wenn ein Nichtraucher da ist, im Hauptraum, und sagt, du, ich hier ist ein Nichtraucher, ich bin hier mit meinem Kind, klar, geh mal ins Raucherkammer, dort ist der Raucherbereich. Nur wenn jetzt einer halt mit seiner Zigarette mal kurz rauskommt, was holen wir da rein, verschwindet, ist es auch nicht so, dass da jetzt die Nichtraucher-Nazis irgendwie meinen, den kreuzigen wir jetzt. Es pendelt sich eher ein. Es geht so viel Zeit oft drauf mit, lass uns mal einen Plan machen.
Wir haben überlegt, ob wir die Fenster vergittern, weil wir Angst gehabt haben. Wir haben so viele abstruse Ideen, im Grunde einfach tun, mit den Dingen beschäftigen, die jetzt wirklich anstehen, die wirklich ein Problem sind. Am Anfang ist das Problem, Leute zu finden, na gut, musst du irgendwas machen, wie findest du Leute? Du erzählst deine Idee weiter, oder du holst Leute dazu, die das Gleiche machen. Irgendwann hast du genug Leute, am besten machst du dann einfach einen Verein. Ich meine, ein Verein hat Haftungsschutz, solange du nicht grob fahrlässig bist, also in Österreich zumindest in der Form, dass du kannst auch einfach mal anfangen und sagen, du machst einen guten Finanzplan, dass die Leute guten Gewissens sagen, das Geld, das könnte funktionieren und so weiter. Du sagst den Leuten, es ist ein Risiko dabei, wollt ihr das machen? Dann machst du mal. Wenn es schief geht, schade. Es ist super cool, dass es so gut geklappt hat, aber ich glaube, wir wären alle mit uns trotzdem zufriedener, wenn das Ganze gescheitert wäre, als hätten wir es gar nicht versucht.
Ich wollte noch mal ein bisschen in diese Lehren, die ihr gehabt habt, einsteigen. Was ist jetzt mehr dabei? Was tue ich als Erstes? Wie kriege ich die Leute zusammen? Klar, da muss man eine Location finden, da muss sich das finanziell ausgehen. Ist klar. Aber was waren denn dann die ersten Konflikte, in die ihr geraten seid? Was waren die Schwierigkeiten, die es zu überwinden gilt?
Ganz wichtig, neue Leute reinholen, also jemand, der jetzt einen Hacker-Space starten will, hat eine hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er schon irgendwo Kontakte zu der Szene gehabt hat. Ganz wichtig ist dann aber auch, einfach neue Leute einzubinden, zuzulassen. Weil meistens die Leute, die schon in vielen Projekten drinnen sind und die Erfahrung haben, sind viel zu beschäftigt und sagen dir, sie machen mit. Also dann einfach nicht verlassen, neue Leute, ganz frische, unbeschriebene Blätter dazuholen und die auch in den Vorstand setzen und einfach die Arbeit machen lassen. Und ein paar Monate mal schauen, was hast du für ein Team? Ja, sonst lernen, wenn du gute Leute hast, passiert alles von selber. Wir haben den Schlüssel bekommen, die Easter Hack war plötzlich da und alles ist passiert, weil wir einfach schon sieben Monate vorher wirklich wöchentlich Treffen gemacht haben. Und die Leute, die das durchgehalten haben, also einfach dabei geblieben sind, haben einfach wirklich wollen. Das war die Leute, die am Anfang dabei waren, wo wir am Anfang geglaubt haben, die werden Arbeiten übernehmen oder Dinge tun, die dann nach einer Zeit einfach weg waren. Die hätten einfach nicht die Zeit gehabt. Also ich glaube, dieses Vorwärtsstürmen, wir müssen die Location sofort haben, das hätte uns auch umbringen können. Hätten wir das Geld am Tag eins gehabt, hätten wir nicht die Leute gehabt, um wirklich was draus zu machen.
Und so im sozialen Miteinander? Das ist ja häufig so. Ich meine, was du schon angesprochen hast, Flo, dieses Bedenkenträgertum, das kenn ich auch sehr gut, das ist schwierig, damit zahl zu kommen. Da muss man sich, glaube ich, einfach drüber hinwegsetzen können. Aber gab es denn sonst noch irgendwelche Probleme mit offiziellen Stellen, gab es irgendwie mit Behörden oder anderen Neidgruppen? Oder ist das eigentlich alles gar kein Problem?
Ich würde sagen, im Großen und Ganzen läuft es sehr gut. Es gibt natürlich immer wieder Reibereien, wie du es immer überall hast. Aber wir sind eine sehr friedliche Gruppe. Da kommt alles ganz gut miteinander klar. Was ich auch sehr gut finde, ist, dass es zwar sehr unterschiedliche Ansichten gibt, vor allem politische Ansichten gehen manchmal total auseinander. Es sind nicht alle so linke-grüne wie ich. Aber halt schon. Und trotzdem klappt es gut miteinander. Die Leute respissen sich gegenseitig. Und man will ja auch gemeinsam da was machen. Darum findet man auch zueinander.
Was ganz wichtig ist, ist, dass du einfach Entscheidungen legitimierst. Es kann einfach gar nicht angehen, dass irgendjemand sagt, wir machen das jetzt so, keine Diskussion. Es muss immer die Möglichkeit zur Diskussion geben. Auf der anderen Seite kannst du nicht immer anfangen, mit einem schwierigen, also wenn wir drei Monate brauchen, um einen Boden auszusuchen im Hauptraum. Höchstdemokratisch bringt das auch nichts, weil da noch immer niemand einkaufen fährt. Wenn jemand sich die Zeit nimmt, einkaufen zu verlegen, dann sucht er einfach mal den Boden aus. Wir haben jetzt in eineinhalb Jahren eine einzige Abstimmung gehabt, eben zur Raumaufteilung. Und es besteht eigentlich bei jeder Entscheidung diese Möglichkeit, wenn man das Gefühl hat, es passiert etwas, was gar nicht erwünscht ist von einer Mehrheit der Mitglieder, die Zahlen, die den Verein tragen, die Energiefreizeit reinstecken, dann kannst du immer einfach eine Abstimmung fordern. Also dann machen wir so ähnlich wie Debian, so Konter, Seid, Schulze, Wahlsystem. Das heißt, für den User bedeutet das, du gehst auf eine Webseite, hast ein paar Optionen, die beigetragen worden sind von anderen Mitgliedern und du wählst nicht jetzt irgendwie Ja, Nein, sondern zum Beispiel im Raumplan haben wir fünf verschiedene Raumpläne submitted bekommen bis zur Deadline und kannst damit drag and drop die nach deinen Präferenzen sortieren. Das würde passieren. Und auch wenn das jetzt nur einmal passiert ist, einfach dieses Wissen, jede Entscheidung, wenn du es wirklich drauf anlegst und jetzt glaubst, das ist nicht im Interesse des Vereins, du könntest es dir einfordern. Und allein das ist mächtig, weil das bedeutet, du musst mit den Leuten reden und mal rausfinden, ob du eine Mehrheit hättest, bevor du dir diese Mühe antust.
Das Debian-System hast du gerade?
Nein, vom Algorithmus dahinter. Die Idee ist einfach dahinter, wenn du... Die Idee dahinter ist einfach, wenn du, sagen wir, jetzt fünf Raumpläne hast und du hast zwei davon, sind sich sehr ähnlich, dann werden die stimmen wahrscheinlich Hälfte, Hälfte auf die beiden verteilt. Zusammen hätten sie eine Mehrheit. Du kriegst einfach nicht das Ergebnis, was sich die Leute wirklich wünschen würden, wenn du einfach nur ein Kreuz halt machen darfst. Und das...
Da gibt es dann so ein Präferenzensystem, das am liebsten und wenn das nicht, dann das.
Bei kritischen Entscheidungen, wie jetzt Personenwahlen oder so, machen wir das teilweise mit Aufzeigen. Also wenn es nicht Wahlgeheimnis ist oder halt mit Urnern. Aber jetzt bei so im Prozess drinnen Entscheidungen mittendrin, halte ich das gar nicht so schlecht mit diesem Wahlsystem. Die Frage ist auch, elektronisches Voting, schwieriges Thema, aber solange du nicht unbedingt auf Anonymität extrem viel Wert setzt, kannst du coole Dinge damit machen.
Ja klar, natürlich. Ich wollte jetzt auch nicht in den Wahlcomputerstrudel ziehen, das ist ja ein anderes Themenfeld. Und um so viel Macht und Geld geht es, glaube ich, im Metalab nun wirklich nicht. Ja, jetzt sind wir schon relativ weit. Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass wir vielleicht so ein paar erwähnenswerte Projekte noch nicht wirklich erwähnt haben.
Ich würde sagen, von der Hardware-Seite gibt es noch den Wizard 23, der Nick total zurecht hat. Er ist der Wizard. Der hat uns dieses MetaSense-System gebaut, was unser interner Sensor-Netzwerk ist, mit Bewegungsmeldern und mit der Türverkabel, dass man sich da beoffen ist.
Luftung, Raumtemperatur, Grafen über die Zeit.
Ja, kannst du sagen, Bewegungsverteilung im Hauptraum, wie in einem Abschnitt von 14 Tagen. Das ist ja nett.
Also sozusagen auch basteln am lebenden Objekt. Man benutzt sozusagen das Metalab selber auch als...
Ja, und sie bauen Roboter, der tut auch jetzt immer wieder mit Kunststudentinnen so coole, also ihnen helfen mit ihren Projekten, Roboter zu bauen, was auch immer. Mit neuronalen Netzen hat er sich beschäftigt. Es sind viele, muss man sagen, viele von den Projekten haben jetzt einfach keinen einzelnen eigenen Namen oder so, weil viele beschäftigen sich halt nicht so viel mit Vermarktung. Also wir haben bemerkt, dass Leute ganz ähnliche Projekte später dann gemacht haben und eine eigene Webseite mit eigener Domain und was sie sich dafür gemacht haben. Und vielen Leuten im Lab liegt das halt auch gar nicht so. Man versucht sich zwar gegenseitig zu unterstützen, es gibt Leute, denen das Marketing ein bisschen mehr liegt, aber so tendenziell ist das halt einfach mühsam. Du willst das Projekt machen und nicht... Das sind dann oft Dinge, die irgendwie verstrickt sind. Wir haben so eine riesig lange Liste mit...
Was ist denn aus diesem Laser geworden?
Laser, Laser-Technik.
Das ist in einen eigenen Verein jetzt übergegangen, ins Graffiti Research Lab Vienna. Also die Arbeiten jetzt mit denen zusammen, die ursprünglich auch die Idee gehabt haben.
Also muss man vielleicht nochmal kurz erläutern, was das ist. Also das Graffiti Research Lab hat vor einiger Zeit große Aufmerksamkeit im Internet erzielt mit einer sehr coolen Installation. Wie war das? Das war ein großer Beamer und dazu noch ein Laser und eine Kamera, die das Ganze filmt. Und da, wo man mit dem Laser auf die Häuserwand trifft, dort wird dann halt gemalt. Und das, was man sozusagen virtuell malt, kommt dann aus dem Beamer. Richtig? Und sowas Ähnliches habt ihr auch gebaut.
Ja, weil die Software irgendwie crappy war. Und drum ist das Ganze neu gebaut worden im Processing. Und Karn ist halt urviel. Hat jetzt auch 3D-Information. Man kann das drehen und farben.
Es ist schon so viel, dass euch das schon gar nicht mehr einfällt. Stimmt?
Ja, ja, es passiert halt viel. Vor allem ist es auch irgendwo, wir sagen eigentlich so tendenziell, es ist schwierig, irgendwo die Grenze zu ziehen. Wir sagen den Leuten, das Metalab, ihr müsst es nicht erwähnen. Es ist kein Metalab-Projekte. Gibt es ja eigentlich nur so beschränkt, wenn sie sich mit Metalab selber irgendwo beschäftigen. Macht ihr eure eigenen Labels, dann kriegt ihr den vollen Credit. Mehr Motivation, mehr Projekte. Ich glaube, das ist ganz eine coole Essenz. Die Leute erwähnen es gerne, weil sie es gerne haben. Aber es ist nicht das Metalab macht die Projekte nicht. Es sind drei Leute, die es machen. Wenn du 100, 140, irgendwas Mitglieder hast, willst du die auch gar nicht immer mitzernen müssen. Es ist, glaube ich, auch beim CTC vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig, wenn ich ein CTC-Projekt mache, und dann habe ich da 1500 Leute irgendwo unter dem Label. Also wir machen da eher Suppellabels. Wir sagen, mach dein eigenes Label für dies, für dies, für dies, für dies. Und nutzt das Lab als Infrastruktur, hol Leute hin. Wenn du Leute triffst, erzähle ihnen vom Lab. Wir wollen mehr, mehr, mehr coole Leute, mehr coole Projekte.
Ja, der Name ist Programm. Also insofern ist es ja eher die Metaebene für diese ganzen Projekte. Unterhaltet ihr denn so für diplomatische Beziehungen zu anderen Hacker-Spaces? Und was ist da für euch noch Einfluss?
Ich glaube, unser großes Vorbild vor der Gründung war das Seabase vom Platz her. Im Prinzip sind wir jetzt aber doch ein bisschen anders. Das Seabase ist viel größer, macht mehr Events, setzt den Schwerpunkt vielleicht auf Barbetrieb und Vermieten. Das machen wir nicht. Wir hatten zwar auch ein paar Partys, aber wir sind jetzt keine Event-Location dafür. Weder groß genug noch ist es die Idee dahinter. Dann gibt es halt das Labor, das sehr viel Hardware macht, was bei uns auch recht ähnlich ist.
Und in Berlin.
Aber auch CCC in Berlin, in Köln. Ein bisschen herumgereist, wir haben nicht alles gesehen. Was ich gehört habe ist auch das Multimedia-Institut MAMA in Sagreb, cool. Da kennen wir die Person und ich war noch nicht dort leider. Der Netzladen auf jeden Fall. Der Jens Olig hat viel Input auch einfach geliefert, auch schon im Vorfeld und auch immer wieder da gewesen. Über Hackerspaces generell philosophiert. Hat sich auch so ergeben, dass, wie wir das Lab gegründet haben, halt auch gerade zwei von CCC, da Angelo und Tina gerade in Wien waren, die da viel, viel Input einfach, weil sie wirklich, bei uns hat ja noch niemand in so einem Platz wirklich gelebt, dort gewesen, sondern einfach immer nur zu Besuch gewesen. Meistens in Berlin. Viel Input einfach geliefert. Wie ist das denn so mit den Alltagsproblemen? Oder einfach viel beschwichtigt, ja, zusammenräumen klappt dort auch nicht, aber es gibt es trotzdem.
Genau.
Aber ihr schließt da ja auch eine interessante Lücke, so rein geostrategisch, das hast du ja schon erwähnt.
Wir haben schon Anfragen gekriegt jetzt von einigen anderen. Dadurch, dass wir einfach so plötzlich von null weg eine Location gehabt haben und halt dadurch viel Dokumentation erstellen haben müssen, haben sich viele andere Städte, also ich weiß nicht, Paris, Madrid, Graz, Linz, New York, alles Mögliche interessiert für die, wie kann man sowas machen? Einfach Feedback von uns zu holen, auch von anderen Plätzen. Was gibt es denn noch für andere Plätze, wo können wir uns umschauen? Also das finde ich spannend. In Linz könnte jetzt ein Projekt entstehen, wo vielleicht sogar ein bisschen Startkapital einfach zur Verfügung wäre, dass man da was machen kann. Also in die Richtung geht es dann wahrscheinlich eher am Beraten, wie finde ich mal die ersten Leute. Oft die Sachen, die ich beobachtet habe, die gescheitert sind, sind meistens daran hängen geblieben, weil sie für sich eine Location bauen wollten. Für sich im Sinne von, mich interessieren diese Dinge. Das ist das Fatalste. Mich interessieren diese Dinge, und ich habe Freunde, die interessieren sich für andere Dinge, und die haben Freunde, die interessieren sich für andere Dinge. Das ist glaube ich der Ansatz, den es wirklich braucht. Das ist aber sehr schwer zu verklickern. Die Leute haben immer eine sehr klare Vorstellung. Wir wollen, es wäre zum Beispiel, wenn das Metalab nur das Elektroniklabor wäre, dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht dort, weil ich nichts mit Elektronik mache. Dann wäre wieder jemand andere auch nicht dort. Es wird nicht funktionieren, du brauchst diese Fehlfalt. Wir versuchen, da auch explizit Leute einzuladen von den Plätzen, die wir kennenlernen. Aus Berlin waren ein paar Mal schon Leute da. Auch aus anderen Städten in Deutschland. Jetzt haben wir mal nach Richtung Osten uns umgeschaut. Aus Budapest den Victor von Nextlab eingeladen gehabt. Ich glaube, das ist irgendwo zeitgeistmäßig. Wir sehen, es wird in den nächsten Jahren mehr entstehen. Jetzt habe ich gerade die Info gekriegt, dass da Pre-Pet ist, der jetzt gerade als Artist in Residenz in Wien ist. Der ist vom Make-Magazin. Dass die in New York recht weit jetzt schon sind, dabei ein eher etwas hardware-lastiges Hacker-Space aufzubauen. Angeblich geht jetzt gerade die Noise-Bridge in San Francisco in der nächsten Zeit online, wo der Jake Appelbaum recht stark involviert ist. Ich glaube, wir sind da gerade mitten in diesem Zeitgeist drin. Und es ist ganz wichtig, dass man sich da mehr zusammenredet und auch gemeinsam Dokumentation erstellt und aus den Fehlern lernt, was der Jens auch begonnen hat mit Design-Patterns für Hacker-Spaces.
Ja, es gibt auch diese Hacker Foundation, die durch Europa getourt ist und sich die Plätze angeschaut hat, um mit dem Ziel in Amerika auch Hacker-Spaces aufzubauen.
Nach dem letzten Camp, das Losgedüß mit dem Bus.
Einmal durch Mitteleuropa.
Das muss eine verrückte Tour gewesen sein.
Ja, das denke ich auch. Ich denke auch, Zeitgeist ist das auf jeden Fall. Metalab hat da einfach den Punkt getroffen. Im Prinzip auch ganz gut zusammengefasst, was schon vorher auch da war. Ist ja schon angeklungen, C-Base und so weiter. C-Base in besonderem ist ein sehr interdisziplinärer Verein. Auch da ist es nicht nur die Nerdkultur, sondern es waren auch so ein Frühnetz-affine Leute, aber auch genauso Leute, die einfach expressiv unterwegs sind. Theater-Performances und ähnliche Sachen. Das hat dann auch wiederum in diese Kultur dieses Ortes reingesteckt. Und das selber dann auch der Geburtsplatz war für neue Projekte. Und ich halte das für eine gute Sache. Und ich hoffe, dass wir noch in vielen anderen Städten solche Läden sehen, wie das Metalab und all die anderen. Ja, in dem Sinne, denke ich, haben wir es jetzt auch mal ganz gut zusammengefasst. Vielen Dank, Flo und Enki. Das war es, Chaosradio Express Nummer 55. Diesmal sage ich auch am Ende die richtige Zahl und nicht für eine andere Sendung die falsche. Aber irgendwelche Fehler werden wir schon gemacht haben. Und wenn ihr welche gefunden habt, dann könnt ihr uns das alles erzählen und schickt uns eine E-Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de oder seid ganz modern und geht auf blog.chaosradio.ccc.de und kommentiert ganz eifrig in dem Beitrag, der dieser Sendung gewidmet ist. Längerfristiges, auch wir haben ein Wiki. Das freut sich immer wieder um Beteiligung. Ja, und ich sage nochmal danke in die Runde und dann verabschieden wir uns auch schön bei den Hörern.